qui succédera à la chancelière angela
merkel en poste depuis seize ans à ces
quatre mandature et sa longévité
exceptionnelle les équilibres politiques
vont-ils chanceler à l'issue des
élections générales allemandes plus de
60 millions d'allemands sont appelés aux
urnes pour renouveler les membres de la
chambre basse du parlement le bundestag
qui eux-mêmes éliront la nouvelle
chancelière le nouveau chancelier
maintien dans le giron conservateur
décalage au centre gauche l'issue est
incertaine
voyons tout d'abord quelles sont les
forces en présence la cds ou l'union
chrétienne démocrate d'allemagne
conservatrice incarnée par la
chancelière sortante mais son chef de
file armin laschet tu peine à rassembler
les suffrages le spd parti de centre
gauche jouent des coudes avec la cd ou
avec lequel il est entré en coalition et
puis hier les sondages l'ont donné
vainqueur à 25% contre 21,8 olaf scholz
l'actuel ministre des finances allemand
pourrait donc devenir chancelier
les deux parties sont talonnés par les
verts crédités de 15,7 pour cent
véritable aiguillon de la campagne anna
lena bareback leur leader pourrait les
faire entrer dans une coalition et les
autres partis sont loin derrière les
libéraux du fdp 11 2% le parti anti
immigration asd 11% et la gauche
radicale die linke 6 5% les allemands
dans ces législatives devraient élire
près de 500 98 députés en théorie car il
y en avait bien davantage lors de cette
dernière mandature
le nombre des députés est en
augmentation depuis 2002 il a atteint
jusque 709 parlementaire en 2017 mais il
pourrait y en avoir encore beaucoup plus
autour de 1000 pourquoi car le système
électoral allemand die scrutin
proportionnel plurinominal est fort
complexe une partie des députés sont
élus via le vote des allemands qui
désigne représentants dans les länder
les circonscriptions c'est le vote
uninominal à la majorité simple qui
concerne 200 99 députés les allemands
doivent voter une seconde fois cette
fois au niveau national et ce vote et
habille la répartition pour la
proportionnelle il vaut pour la
composition de l'hémicycle il prime sur
les résultats des circonscriptions
il faut donc rétablir les pourcentages
du vote national au sein du bundestag
alors qu'un certain nombre de partis ont
déjà fait entrer leurs représentants à
la première élection des länder le
système prévoit de reproduire les scores
en compensant avec l'entrée de députés
inscrits sur les listes des partis élus
au niveau national mais attention
complexité quand tu nous tiens le leader
du parti gagnant ne pourra pas être
nommé chancelier s'il ne parvient pas à
faire une coalition qui obtiennent la
majorité au bundestag pour son dernier
mandat angela merkel avait dû batailler
sont dix-sept jours avant d'obtenir une
alliance suffisante et jeudi soir eu
lieu le dernier débat réunissant les
représentants des sept partis avec des
discussions sur le logement ou la
politique étrangère est en ligne de mire
les fameuses alliance qui permette
d'assurer la majorité parlementaire
alors que le spd l'a cédée ou sont
proches dans les sondages le ralliement
des libéraux pourraient être décisifs on
sait que ces derniers préfèrent une
coalition cd ou et vert en tout cas la
prochaine chancelière ont le prochain
chancelier aura de nombreux chantiers
laissés en jachère par angela merkel à
reprendre le vieillissement de la
population le manque d'infrastructures
le problème des travailleurs pauvres et
bien entendu la gestion jusqu'ici très
moyenne de la transition écologique avec
un pays toujours plus dépendants du
charbon depuis sa décision de sortie du
nucléaire des défis de taille